let's go to joe
joe in uh new york hey uh with the
sports betting apps legal in new york
now who do you like in the nfl playoffs
this year all of new york will be broke
now it's like you go to otb it's strewn
with losers
and broken tickets and dreams uh i know
for a fact john hein is already homeless
and that's only three days in
but uh a lot of my guys are into the
sport he's gonna have a field day now
don't take my advice if you're betting
money because what i know about sports
can fit into a thimble i like jd's
bengals
i gotta say
they had a good season right jd you got
to be pumped up he's a big bengals guy
even though he's now lived in new york i
don't know what he's doing with
cincinnati but okay he's been loyal to
them and even when they sucked he was a
lawyer
are you excited about the bangles i'm
very excited i will cry i will cry for
sure if they win they haven't won a
playoff game since you know in 30 years
so any game if they win any of the
playoff games you'll be crying jd is the
worst winner he's tweeting all over the
place he's tweeting all over the place
he tweeted the following
when the bengals won last week jd
tweeted holy [ __ ] kings of the north
hashtag damn right
uh
jd regular season game
oh yeah okay they're [ __ ] stealers
backed into the [ __ ] playoffs we'll
see how far they make it in steelers
deserve to be in the playoffs my friends
first of all shame on the two of you new
york has been good to both of you and
and john is a steelers fan jd you're off
your rocker with ban bangles
jd has gone as far as to say he is
willing to eat horse [ __ ] like that
eagles fan did if the bengals win the
super bowl now that's great really
well listen i might have been a little
uh carried away with myself after when i
texted that text that to friends you
know when i when a town like new york
has been so good to me this idea that jd
is a bengals fan
and john is a pittsburgh steelers fan is
so [ __ ] repulsive to me you two guys
are crazy and now i heard the ultimate
craziness
ronnie is becoming a las vegas raiders
fan
um now that he lives in las vegas
to be a fan of the town that you live in
ah come on this is a guy who's in new
york
[ __ ] whole
i life that doesn't even make sense
that's crazy well actually the raiders
are facing the bengals this week in the
first playoff game so [ __ ] the raiders
sorry you're you're now a mr las vegas
uh you're the raiders fan ronnie i don't
know there's something about this team
here um
they're just like always down and
there's all kinds of [ __ ] going on with
their players and crap it's like they
come back from
nothing and all of a sudden they win
so it's like a really cool story and uh
i'm watching the games what would be the
ultimate matchup for television i still
think it would be brady
going up against belichick am i
correcting this thought
i think that's the that's the story that
people will write about
all day long
i think you're incorrect
just for the record what's going to get
a bigger audience than that
well well bigger audience i mean you
want bigger audience or do you want a
great game
everyone knows tom brady for christ's
sake and i'll tell you what i want to
see brady
up against belichick i love that
howard it's the story of my life you
know when i would get fired from a radio
station i'd say [ __ ] you man you just
made the biggest mistake your life and i
go on the other radio station do you see
what i mean it's a good well you know
what's interesting is that it was always
like who needs who does belichick need
brady or does brady need belichick you
know what howard if belichick gets back
to the super bowl that's a huge story
because everybody's like when brady left
it was over it was done and he managed
to get this team
relevant again very quickly howard an
appetizer for you would be green bay
they're the number one seed that's aaron
rodgers is their quarterback so brady's
going to have to beat aaron rodgers if
the seeds hold in order
come on
battleground don't we hate you and don't
we hate aaron rodgers i forget
was the one who lied about his vaccine
status that
thank you robin that [ __ ]
i hope brady kicks his ass that would be
a good rivalry